[Music]
so the monster verse is about to come
back to life with the Monarch series and
by the time you see this video it might
have already been released on Apple TV
so go check it out anyway just to get
you on track and prepare you for the
show here are 10 things you need to know
before watching it let's get to it
firstly Godzilla the king of the
monsters still is classified as a
massive unidentified terrestrial
organism or a Muto and so are the other
monsters since the term Titans was only
coined before the events of
2019 king of the monsters the term would
later be attached to the gensan Mushi
species exclusively which are now
popularly known as the mutos but I think
they would use that term uh as well as
monsters and creatures here in this
series instead of the popular Titan
nomenclature secondly let's take a look
at the secret organization called
Monarch this agency has a secret origin
story it was a small organization in the
early years which would start in the
early 1950s under Lee Shaw Bill Randa
and moo it would later be expanded with
the Congressional funding in 1973 to go
to scull Island on that mission and
would only grow slowly over the course
of the 1980s and the 1990s Anyway by
2014 it will be a very well founded
entity with eyes and ears everywhere and
hence such a secret group would be
thought of as a nemesis or at least in a
suspicious manner thirdly so as for Kong
and Skull Island they were both only
discovered in 1973 so there won't be any
reference to The Big Ape in the early
1950s flashbacks but it might make some
appearance or might be mentioned in the
2014 to5 time frame although by the
modern times there would would have
already been missions more missions to
the place as per the animated series and
the birth of COG events and so a base of
operations would have been initiated or
already set up after the 2014 mut battle
fourthly the hollow Earth entry points
were only speculations back in the early
beginnings of Monarch they were only
theories and hypothesis during the
foundation of that organization and
these portals would only be later
confirmed in the events of Kong Skull
Island in 1973 not in the earlier 1950s
flashback so the hollow Earth existence
itself is still only in theory and
hasn't been discovered which would only
happen between the events of kotm and
GVK and the first successful Mission
there would be during GVK alongside Kong
himself okay number five next let's see
which of the many Titans have been
discovered as of the modern timeline
okay so these would be Rodan which was
discovered in Isa de Mara in 1991 Mothra
in in southern China in the unan
province in a temple of the moth in 2009
Monster Zero before 2014 in Antarctica
behind the wall of serpents the other
fan favorites like methusa Sila and
Behemoth were only discovered around the
year 2014 itself the muros were stumbled
upon in 1999 and the other ones all the
other ones have vague dates attached to
them number six so in the trailers you
would have seen Godzilla in the ocean in
the midst of Tropical Islands in the
Pacific these are the bikini atols where
the Gman makes landfall in 1954 and it
is the same location where we saw in the
opening scenes of the first Godzilla
2014 movie and this is him chasing the
shinamura Swarm tiran over there Leed by
the US military under the directions of
a young leea Leed there to be killed by
a hydrogen bomb the Castle Bravo
test number seven so you should also
know that Humanity as of both timelines
in the 1950s and the 20145 modern
timeline they have absolutely no idea
about the existence of these massive
monsters believing them to be only the
stuff of myths and legends when Godzilla
battled the muros in 2014 it was the
first time they had ever seen the king
of the monsters and therefore this theme
would be explored in detail in the
series especially the aftermath of
discovering that Humanity isn't at the
top of the food
chain number eight so for some that
don't know dummies godzill will develop
the new dosel plates here in the series
those that were different from the 2014
version which was sharp and Jagged this
was the result of the deadly and
life-threatening battle against the muto
Prime in Montana in the same year as the
San Francisco event just a few months
afterwards his old dosel plates were
Shattered by a poal Sonic Screech by the
prime which resonated with his body's
internal frequency thus destroying them
and the and then later they would evolve
into the more Maple Leaf shaped on seen
in kotm
onwards number nine there will be
questions asked well about Apex
cybernetics the corporation behind the
construction of Mecca Godzilla this
entity as a fully fledged Corporation
hasn't existed yet during the time of
the series but after the events of San
Francisco Simmons the would be CEO of
Apex and the antagonist in GVK was an
already influential person in the world
and at time of the series he would begin
to find ways to link up with monar and
try to kill Godzilla after the mut
battle driving him to the long procedure
of building a robo Gojira by kotm he
would have already been working with
Monarch and the military which is
evident by him getting access to the
oxygen Destroyer information and
building it and also later getting the
gidora
skulls and number 10 lastly the couple
which were seen in kotm Mark Russell and
Emma Russell have already built built a
working prototype of the Ora device
which allows people to make certain
Communications with other animal species
like the Titans and am mutos using their
frequencies the Orca was in fact created
in 2005 and these two were approached by
the secretive organization and then
later funded and activated as Monarch
agents in 2007 so they are already quite
knowledgeable about Titans in the modern
timeline in fact Emma Russell assisted
Godzilla in his final confrontation with
the mut Prime while Russell with be in a
state of depression at this time due to
the loss of his son in the San Francisco
battle so those are the 10 things you
need to know before watching Monarch the
legacy of monsters anyway check out our
channel for other videos like subscribe
and we'll see you in the next one take
care fam